constant like I can't make this happen
it's it's irritating especially to
somebody like me I always say I grew up
behind the Staten Island dump I grew up
in a small condo my parents worked to
pay the mortgage I didn't come from a
family with money my my grandma was one
of the coolest people I knew street
smart she could run rings about anybody
I swear to God she passed away at I
think it was 101 or 102. she stopped
school in the seventh grade like they
didn't have money they didn't come from
that type of elitism they were all
badass I kind of got that badass Gene so
I've been jumping around I got myself
through school I got those scholarships
I can't stand these oh forgive the loans
forgive what loans nothing was forgiven
I had to work my off to get that
scholarship to get ahead to get where I
wanted to go I went I got these media
jobs I did free TV that's why I have a
big microphone and people who are
sitting at home and didn't do all that
they don't want to hear that they don't
want to hear that